[Music]
if you ask most Americans do they
respect and have confidence in our men
and women in uniform they will give a
resounding yes but when you scratch the
surface this patina of respect for our
military turns out to be a mile wide but
less than an inch deep first of all very
few Americans are willing to actually
serve in uniform during World War two
argue you know admittedly a total war
and probably the peak of mobilization
about thirteen percent of our population
was in uniform today the military
participation ratio is less than half of
one percent and so the burden of
America's global presence has been borne
disproportionately by a very small
percentage of our society and I don't
think there's an easy fix to this going
back to a draft for example would not
guarantee that the burden of service
would be equally felt and likewise there
were all sorts of political and
practical arguments about doing it so
what I'm calling for is simply a broader
recognition of the fact that behind our
sort of gaudy pro-military rhetoric and
our cheering at football game flyovers
or at NASCAR skydiving jumps that we
also think about affirmative support for
our military also involving care about
when we send the men and women in
uniform in harm's way
and it's easy to do that when our kids
or the kids of our best friends are not
likely to serve in uniform and to bear
the burden of any decision to use
military force and so that I think also
ought to be a way of supporting the
troops not only waving the flag but also
saying we're not going to ask you to
potentially make the ultimate sacrifice
unless we're really sure it's necessary
to the security of the rest of our
country and many of us I think in the
restraint camp feel a moral obligation
to our men and women in uniform to be
careful and be selective about the use
of military force given that such a
small percentage of our countrymen are
actually bearing that burden
[Music]